I think for better or for worse, the
consistent problem has always been how
do you help your customers be more
successful? If you would ask me 5 years
ago, "Oh, the price of building features
has decreased. That's obviously good." I
think I would have probably said yes.
And I think that like the TLDR of this
video is like
unclear.
This is Dalton plus Michael, and today
we're going to talk about how to build
an MVP
in the age of AI.
This is an interesting topic cuz I
actually think we have to disagree with
our former advice or there's a different
set of constraints now. It used to be
the case you had to figure out what's
the smallest set of features to build
that would create value because
building features was costly.
We're now in maybe a different
situation. It What environment are we in
now?
>> I think that's completely right. I think
much has been said of how to build an
MVP and get first customers. And there's
you know, we've talked about it, there's
great content out there. But I think
that advice needs updating to AI tools.
And I could speak to this myself a
little bit because I recently
built a product and and launched it. You
know, it's called Standard EDB if people
want to check it out, but we won't we
won't talk about the specifics, but
guys, I've gone I've gone through this.
I just built and launched a product. And
so let me start with what's different.
Number one, it is so much easier to
build features
that
for me to launch that, I had to delete
80% of the features that I built in the
MVP.
>> That's That That is not an old problem.
That is a very new problem.
>> I built this crazy huge thing with my
co-founder Brian in 2 weeks.
And I'm like, "Oh, this is bad. This is
This is like a bunch of crap." And so I
had to I had to
>> Huh.
>> Yeah.
>> And that feels very different to me than
just trying to build a product like the
difficulty of building something
prevented you from from getting into
that feature creep.
>> Yeah.
Or that feature creep would take months.
>> Yes.
>> Whereas you're basically you got feature
creep in two weeks.
>> creep in two weeks. And so you see
people just by coding just crap.
>> Yes.
>> And it's because it's so easy to just
keep adding and adding and adding.
>> Yes.
>> And so I think that
you also have to be more of an editor
than you did in the past.
>> That's a big one.
>> Right?
>> I might argue
it also makes it far more challenging
when you're building a product for
someone else. Cuz when you're building a
product for yourself, at minimum you can
use it throughout the MVP process and
see if you're getting value.
When you're building a product for
someone else and you can build infinite
features,
your brain can be like, "Well, they
would want this feature. They would want
that feature. They would want Why would
I want to go to them with something that
doesn't have all the features they're
going to want?
>> Right? Why don't I give them all the
features they want right in the
beginning?
>> Well, and it's addicting
>> Yeah.
>> to write the feature.
>> It's fun to like tell Codex.
>> And so I think what I'm arguing is
>> It's more tempting now than ever
>> Yes.
>> to not talk to users
>> and to not launch
with something small.
>> I want to extend that. And when you talk
to users and they gave you the laundry
list of features, in the past you knew
you couldn't build all that. So early
smart people did. And so your instinct
would be, "Let me try to dig deeper. Let
me try to figure out what they really
need. What's really going on?" Now in
the hand you have all the features like,
"Hey, can you describe those in more
detail?"
>> we can literally just give those to
>> Yeah, let me make an extreme point.
>> You can take
>> notes
with granola of you're talking to a user
and feed them to Codex and Codex will
build every feature the user asked for.
>> Yes.
>> And I'm saying that's really bad.
>> Yeah.
>> Like don't do it.
>> That's the counterintuitive bit is
it's always been a theory of old to
build every feature a user wants, but
now it's an exponential theory of old
because you can. Like you actually could
do that. And that's really, really,
really bad. Unfortunately, I think as a
result, knowing yourself about the
problem
is way more important now. Because like,
if you don't know about the problem
and users are telling you features and
they're excited, and you don't know what
the hell's going on,
you can get yourself in a like you you
you basically have created a tar pit.
Like like you like where one never maybe
have existed. You you you are the tar
pit.
>> And again, I'm saying I experience like
I I feel this viscerally where it's so
easy to crank stuff out. And so, I think
the advice here founders is you have to
try harder than ever to resist the
temptation of building super complex
broad surface area products. And of
course you should add more features to
it, but it should be because users are
pulling you towards building more stuff,
I think, and not
because Codex could crank it out.
>> Well, let's talk about that users bit.
So, okay, it's easier to build products.
I was about to say I can't believe I'm
saying this, but of course I can believe
I'm saying this. Spamming is easier,
too. Spamming always gets easier. Like
that's the history.
So,
let's talk about that.
>> You know, the old advice is have 100
people that love your product. The old
advice is talk to as many users as
possible. Again, it's all true. We're
not saying that's wrong. Here's the
problem. It's easier than ever to have
your claw
spam people or you to go buy a bunch of
leads online and spam people. And so a
lot of founders,
their version of talking to users
>> It's perverted.
>> It's just it's to like spam.
And it's easy and the numbers are big.
And again, so here's the
counterintuitive thing.
Don't do it.
That is noise.
>> Yes.
>> And a smaller number of high-quality
conversations where you really listen
>> Yeah.
>> is much better than spamming a thousand
people.
>> If we want to go one step deeper, right?
If startups were as simple as talk to
users, build what they want, so many
more startups be successful.
Fundamentally, you have to assume that
most of your users want their business
or their project to be successful and
they don't exactly know how.
So, some fundamental part of what you're
doing
is 10x harder because you're trying to
figure out how to help your customer's
business do better and your customer
doesn't have that playbook perfectly. By
talking to a smaller number of customers
more intimately, it massively increases
the chances that you can actually make
an impact in their business.
And then that spins a flywheel that's
not spam, it's word of mouth.
>> Again, let me give you my real example
for what I did with Standard DB.
>> Yes.
>> We built a bunch of stuff and then I set
up 12 Zoom calls
>> Yes.
>> with founders that I knew that I that
are in the that could be users of it.
>> Yes.
>> My co-founder founder and I joined and I
we just asked them and a lot of people
didn't really understand what it was
>> Yeah.
>> because it was too complicated.
>> And my I tried to explain what it was
and they're like, "Oh, I don't know."
And so we when we stripped out 80% of
the functionality
>> Yeah.
>> they were like, "Yeah, I'm I'm signing
up right now." Like someone signed up on
the call.
>> There you go.
>> And that's counterintuitive. Less
features, more usage.
>> Isn't that weird? It's because they
didn't they were like overwhelmed
>> Yeah.
>> by too much complexity.
>> Yes.
>> And my vision I had this expansive
vision of what it could be, but man,
like users don't care about that. They
just want to know how to solve their
short-term problems.
>> No.
>> Right?
>> No. I think for better or for worse the
consistent problem has always been
how do you help your customers be more
successful? And
if you had asked me five years ago, "Oh,
the price of building features has
decreased. That's obviously good." I
think I would have probably said yes.
And I think that like the TLDR of this
video is like
unclear.
>> I was
Look, I think about this a lot. So, I I
was tweeting about this a little bit.
So, I don't know if you saw it. I'll
tell you about it.
Think about how hard it was to get a
record made
in the '60s.
>> Mhm.
>> You needed a label deal, you had to pay
for studio time, you needed instrument
you know, it's like super expensive. How
many people created a radio quality
record in the '60s? Thousands?
>> Mhm.
>> Now, you buy a Mac.
>> Yeah.
>> And it comes with GarageBand.
>> Yes.
>> And a lot of number one hits, you can
research this, were made in GarageBand.
>> Yes.
>> So, you're using the same tools
>> that the greatest people in the world
are using. Yes. Now,
how much more demand is there
for music than there was in the '60s?
>> Mhm.
>> It's flat.
>> Like, how many hours a day can people
listen to music?
>> People are not living more than 24 hours
a day.
>> And how many people wake up every day
being like, man, I really want to hear
some songs written by, you know, some
guy in Illinois
>> that no one's ever heard of.
>> that no one's ever heard of. Gee, I
really
Like Like, no one wants that. And so,
this is my metaphor for a lot of the
Vibe Coding stuff, which is
in the right hands, it's awesome.
>> Yes.
>> Is a thing to do for fun. I love making
songs in GarageBand. I'm not going to
release that. Sorry, folks. But like,
it's fun to make music.
>> Yes.
>> But I am under no uh delusions
that like the crap that I make in
GarageBand
>> Yeah.
>> is going to be a number one hit.
>> It's going to put you on tour.
>> I don't think so. Oh, there's no demand
for it. And no, I don't have the talent.
>> Exactly.
>> And so, my theory is the democratization
of these tools is awesome and it's going
to allow more
young people to be discovered
>> and to like
>> Yes.
>> break into the industry. Hooray.
>> But the total um
>> winners
>> number of winners is not obviously going
to go up.
>> No.
>> Right, man?
>> Well, and what's funny about this is
that when you're building tools for
yourself,
um you know, I would argue that like an
employee inside of a company is now so
much more empowered with these tools
when they have a clear job to do and
they know how to do it. And now it's
like they don't have to tax the
company's resources,
they probably get a much higher
multiplier effect than the startup.
>> It's true. I mean, it's the it's like
think about how many people are employed
um making videos for like internal
training purposes or for whatever versus
people that are making Hollywood
blockbusters. You know, like or how many
directors are in the world?
>> Yes.
>> And so probably there's lots and lots of
people who use these tools to get their
job done that might not be creating the
next Facebook.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
So, TLDR, building an MVP, E, and the I
were all different. Features,
I've always thought features are bad,
but now features are cheap. Oof, scary.
>> You just have to be picky and like maybe
one more thing is a lot of our advice
was always to build in public into
publish a lot about what you're doing.
>> Mhm.
>> And the problem is
the claws make it so easy
>> Yeah.
>> to create crap on LinkedIn and X about
what you're building and it's all the
same.
>> Yes.
>> Versus if you take the time
to write really unique stuff, you can
build a following. And so I I again, I
see a lot of founders just putting out
slop versus like Arko, he writes about
file systems all the time. 100 guys
constantly. And he's building a
following cuz it's super idiosyncratic
writing about file systems.
>> Yes.
>> Ironically also, the best content to
learn about what the labs are working on
is the Twitter accounts of people that
work at the labs and they are definitely
not writing all that stuff.
Do you get what I'm saying? Like they're
leaking alpha.
>> Exactly. It's a weird game. It's
basically like it's become easier for a
startup to basically look like it's
going through a positive feedback loop
when it's actually secretly going
through a negative feedback loop.
>> Yeah.
>> Spam bunch of customers,
get their usage, they don't like the
product, they all churn out, keep doing
it, da da da da. But that's an advantage
in a weird way. Like if more of your
competition's doing that and you're not,
you can figure out how to use these
tools in the measured way to actually
create value for people,
there is tons of advantage to pick up
right now.
Tons of advantage.
>> And it's almost like
the people that are the best
at editing or creating white space
>> Yeah.
>> and focusing
>> Yes.
>> I think are like really well positioned
when everyone else is doing the
opposite. Like that's a way to stand out
from the crowd.
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> We have two features that work.
That actually make your business better.
Or make your life better. Yes.
>> As opposed to 150 that you might be
confused initially. Obviously the thing
with 150 features is better. Then when
you start using it, you're like,
no, thank you.
>> You got it.
>> All right.
>> Cheers, Alton.
>> All right, thanks.